basta a saga capriche que eu quero ser
tri no méxico pina no pan de idéia e aí
olha que o campeonato bom vocês estamos
aqui antes de começar esse ótimo lance
passar esse vídeo tá ótimo garante novo
pra vocês eu queria pedir um negócio que
vocês o meu colega eu tenho um colega
que está participando hoje ganho nas
escolas é conseguir muitas curtidas e 1
foto como é meu colega lógico vai ajudar
aqui na descrição tenha em conta que é
só clicar no link está lá já vai abrir a
foto seria fazer nada só precisa curtir
pra um sinal de que você votou para
ouvi-la que estava presente se recomenda
hashtag o endereço me trouxe aqui para
ajudar um amigo também está na tela não
é que a gente ir ajudou em nosso
exército você pode fazer pra mim
perceber clicou no link curtiu a foto
comentou isso aí tá beleza muito
obrigado se você fez isso muito obrigado
a voltar o vídeo 4 45 da manhã gravando
o vídeo pra quem pra quem é a mãe podia
nos página
o dia dos pais também fala baixo que
hoje os pais além do grupo aktuell
incomodar o pessoal que está pensando se
eu ia fazer um vídeo para que por que
que eu não sabia fazer pedido dos pais
pelo dia dos pais um dia me esquecido
não é quando se fala a palavra pai é uma
coisa que você fala mamãe no cinema de
que você fala mãe você me odiar pé
carinho de amor de tudo o que há de bom
ela quer fala o pai propôs além do
cinturão falando da maia no escuro com
que cara por que tanto ódio no coração
de vocês vão te dá rosas e kaká o
coração porque a mãe é aquela figura que
está mais presente itália da figura que
marca mais assim o pai não vai estar
sempre trabalhando nele chega e vai ver
o filho passa porque lá há emprego um
pouco conversa vai dormir aí no outro
dia vai trabalhar novo e acaba que num
não consegue ficar muito presente é
consequentemente benazzi não haja mais
lembrada do dia dos pais é uma
específica um pouquinho pena porque o
dia das mães é assim
[Música]
ai ai ai querida meu coração por the map
dos pais é assim o pai no prédio de
reais que dia das mães é coisa de deus
né
o pai o pai está sempre lá quieto lá
andei a mãe
um beijão já tá um dia das mães que não
emitem ondas lá quem deca ano de dados
mas vereador aquele vestindo as filhas
que acabam para fazer coisa pra mãe
chama carro de som na que entendem que
ele estava bonita para o celso portiolli
vai para afetar a cavalo pampa cheio de
balão principado 10 mandou no reinado
que da manhã carro de som igualzinho a
isso aqui neste dia tão especial e o seu
filho josé carlos e jacques terrorista
na chave é neto do dono do bar fitness
da silva ele parabenizou por mais um dia
especial
mamãe você é muito importante para mim
amo mamãe você não sabe o quanto você é
importante para mim mesma maneira os
pais é assim
é o pessoal fácil mas por que é tão
valorizado dia das mães e dos pais no
essencial que eles conheciam mas amanhã
é a figura que mais sofre
a mãe passou nove meses com você dentro
dela e digo sim meu pai passou mais de
20 anos eu não me envolvo demais ou
perder nunca reclamou a academia você
tem que pensar no mundo naquela coisa
você carregar o menino nove meses dentro
de você se pintarem os pais que têm mais
de um milhão dentro deles é também muito
hora tem que botar pra fora e pegue sair
nós eu acho mais engraçado entregou de
papai noel porque sentem aquele aquela
confusão de quem manda na casa que é um
item trabalho chato que nunca ele está
mais alta ontem caso queda maior do que
o outro caso que ainda mais nessa casa
de show eu cada momento você vai pedir
que seu pai pra sair aí fala peça passou
a mãe você vai ter bola somente uma
semana deixou sair essa parceria o pai
estava andando de toda cria um mundo
infinito que você fica com tanta raiva
diz que vai pagar o pato não tem mais de
perto uma coisa muito engraçada sobre
python eu acho graça que sempre o km
muito linda ela é muito linda endeusa da
crise no brasil a minha torre da marinha
também está a pagar podem comer é doce
de leite isso se ela carece ainda não
seria nem todo mundo assim aumentar na
forma da festa da chery logicamente
chamou para buscar ela chegou para no
pai parece orangutan com o senhor o pai
da menina está muito para mim para minha
parada vital para a minha família para a
menina pra mim tá no meio do ano para
mim o meu deus do céu as desgraças diz
mas como diabos que sai do saco nunca
deixou nenhum tão perfeita 10
aí você vai ver quem é bonita filha à
mãe por isso o povo de deus a graça
por mais barrico de pôr mais baixo o
mais estranho que seja o marco unita tem
a coragem do nosso país não tem quem
faça o caixão ficará muito que o pai a
gente olha a gente [ __ ] povo é em todo
na festa para eu ir pra festa para o pai
deles porque o pai não deixe de perder
você tem muito pai fora que está sendo
filho foi para a festa não vou tomar as
mudas se você tem pais e das chances e
vídeo uma lata desejo agradecer por tudo
que ele já fez porque tem muita gente
taxa selic agora que não tem mais pai
queria te e você aí tem e o download já
que aproveitar aqui o manual feliz dia
dos pais com o pai que está lá e morreu
está 47 anos que não digo acho que é o
primeiro dia dos pais para o padrão meu
pai então eu eo ganso tivesse chance de
água sai por seu fã e marquinhos e mais
do que um pai pra mim o herói muito
obrigado por tudo que seja tem feito por
mim por todos nós
la família e um senhor e é isso aí então
se você está assistindo esse vídeo você
gostou desse vídeo você por favor em
consideração o meu trabalho e sei lá
como se fosse uma retribuição por eu ter
feito você que um pouco vão ficar que eu
gostei e comente aqui embaixo que você
acha mais engraçado os pais de vocês
pode deixar sua homenagem para ele aqui
nos comentários
se você não está inscrito e se tornar o
que inscrever se eu tiver de novo você
vai saber se você
no facebook por favor me ajude que
querem compartilhar semana e alguns
amigos seus beber e compartilhe que me
ajuda curte que me ajuda muito também e
em 100 as redes sociais dão toda a
descrição do vídeo kersey falou